if someone annoys you you need to be
that [ __ ] you do and stand up to
yourself so they don't forget you gonna
walk down the street feel the wind
blowing in your head and be like today
we are joined by the queen of pop oh and
now she's the face of its retail all
right well you are bringing the sparkles
the glam and the glitter all in one up
today you know I come easily to a party
I have to make it in truth what has been
the most inspiring piece of ice that
shaped your life would you say a heart
are you as fun because it was very
special and the moment was very special
and I was told from someone who's very
famous and incredibly successful in
music and he said to me you know what
when you read something about yourself
in the moment you think it's the worst
thing in the world and you think
everyone in the world thinks the same
thing yeah but that's only because it's
you and you have to remember that
probably not everyone even knows what
talking about you have to keep that in
mind this for you being it in it and
you're you you're just like oh my god
the whole world thinks whatever
so I've learnt to really take things
into like pictures of soul so you can
learn to take yourself out of the
situation yes yeah it took a long trials
and errors don't get me wrong for like
taking things with the pinch of salt is
probably like the best advice I ever got
but also do you think as well it's
become easy to block out negativity
because all say like we are living in
the world for there's so much negativity
on social media I mean yeah it's really
really crazy yeah like the cyberbullying
is next level it's it's intense have you
ever let that get to you is that motto
really got you through I think what got
me through is just the confidence I have
with what I do I think that really makes
you want to get up in the morning and
like do something else because I'm so
happy to be able to do what I love and
not a lot of people have that and I
think that I don't take that for granted
so I use it in a good way
and even just collaborating or doing
something the jewelry anything that
could keep a memory in someone I mean
you're like that's not really my jobs
like done yeah but also one realizing
things you've done recently which is the
UNICEF it during days and I watched it
and I was like that was very emotional
what was the hardest thing for you doing
that journey a bit going on that journey
it was a big moment for me as a person
and in my career like out of everything
that I've done so far that was a really
standout moment for me in my career
because I'm from that place in the world
and so it touched really sensitive spots
for me knowing that that sort poverty
exists like two hours away from the UK
or like from London and there was a lot
of mixed emotions but at the same time
seeing the effects that charities do
have because you know sometimes you see
things and you're just like oh you never
see the outcome of these charities you
know a lot of people are like what does
that actually do but it's the first time
hence why I wanted to be an ambassador
of UNICEF I actually really saw results
and it was first time they went to the
place that the person was from so
everyone was a bit emotional and I think
you can tell the vanilla yeah do you
think you were doing it for that little
girl I was doing it for her and I was
also doing it for I have family members
also still live in Kosovo so you know
there was a lot of reasons why I was
doing what I was doing
it's such an incredible things you use
your platform yeah to do that kind of
thing yeah with a buddy when you realize
that was such important things is you
and your platform could change lives you
know you have influence when you are
high-profile like myself whenever like a
lot things going on but you don't
realize the effects you have verbally
until you like see it in real life and
to be able to raise as much money as we
did it was kind of like wow it works you
know
yeah and so that was an awesome feeling
I felt a bit like a superhero because I
was like whoa the Cape was really strong
this time it was really strong yeah
loving it auntie no way strong today
baby your jewels thank you but you know
where they have an amazing silver
collection also but you know today I'm
doing gold I don't really pick between
silver and older for me I just like
metal I feel like doesn't happen there
so it does it really is they've been
making all that design for decades get
the programs okay get with it you're
thinking before me say and you see more
empowered really never before no way do
you feel like that yeah it's been a
journey though and I'm not even like at
close to where I would have been and I
think I have so much more to do but I do
I feel more empowered every day because
some days I don't wake up like I'm a
boss [ __ ] you know sure sometimes I
wake up like oh man and I think it just
comes in phases and you've just got to
be prepared for it and I think even with
what I do I'm still human you know so
you've got to be like I've got to do
this cuz you've got to keep it going for
your fans and I think also that is a
great manner to happen life is there
yeah that [ __ ] you have to be that rich
do you have to be that because you know
if someone annoys you you need to be
that [ __ ] you do and stand up to
yourself so they don't with you again
yes yeah Oh loving the clay you gonna
walk down the street feel the wind
blowing in your hair and be like I got
this like that no it's definitely it's
definitely a bit of an effort like later
glancing colors which is why this was
like a perfect fit for me to do a
collaboration it just kind of I'm just
kind of do I usually do which is this
where everything oh yes once yes why not
it's work here that they don't like want
me to change is episode sure thing is
too much not for never not for me but
maybe that's why you know some people
look at me like what the hell does she
wear and some people are like good for
you've been a comedian when it comes to
style yeah yeah yeah you've been through
some phases
thank you you had the bandanas there's
been the glam and the glitter I did it
all you ticked it laughs cut my hair off
shaved it off I used to have like no I
don't know you know what I just get
bored easily
you can't tell with my music and like
the fact that I haven't taken a step
back in like 10 years
mm-hmm just goes to show that I'm just
so obsessed with my work and I just love
playing with clothes and like being able
to just like express my
so creatively sick it's just the best
job ever because how do you use like I
would say beauty and fashion and style
in jewelry to empower you would you say
how's it in pound
you know I think as I'm getting older
it's changing for me like when I first
started I you know in this job I was
just kind of like I love everything and
blah blah blah
now I'm being a bit older I'm starting
to understand like the pickings and the
same being saying no to things so I
think I feel more empowered knowing that
I can make make a choice now with why I
do not just my life but like in clothes
I wonder we like hot pants in a bra or
if I want to wear like a floor-length
gown I think it's also a great thing
that we are living in this day and age
where women can do whatever the hell
they want yeah and they shouldn't have
to face repercussions of like you know
like sexist people German yes something
like oh yeah I just think times are
changing you know and I think as an
artist it's part of our job to be
ourselves because we were supposed to
inspire and admire
[Music]
[Applause]